le Berry et ses champs à perte de vue la
carte postale semble idylique et
pourtant cette campagne se vide petit à
petit de ses habitants et en particulier
de ses
agriculteurs matthieu a 28 ans et
cherche à s'installer depuis plusieurs
années en désespoir de cause il a fondé
son entreprise de prestation de service
agricole gonzac 33 ans s'est installé
mais c'est considérablement endetté il
mène de front deux métiers pour
survivre Damien 21 ans et lycéen il se
prépare à affronter la complexité de
l'installation tous ces jeunes
agriculteurs veulent avoir leur propre
terre et s'installer à leur
compte bienvenu dans leur
monde
matthie CPR est un homme pressé comme
tout agriculteur qui se respecte il part
travailler tous les matins dans les
champs des champs qui ne sont pourtant
pas les siens matthie est prestataire il
travaille chez les
autres je Deir de préparer cherch
tracteur ça soit pr aprèsmidi et pu mon
salar par a
PR
ce jour
jour vie il l'a choisi à défaut de
pouvoir s'installer le but c'était
d'avoir son exploitation ses terres son
matériel une femme des enfants trop
d'investissement trop cher il a dû
renoncer du moins provisoirement
j'aurais voulu trouver une exploitation
type 150 hactar céréales et cetera dans
lequel j'aurais pu vivre correctement
enfin à peu près je pouvais pas donc
j'ai plutôt monté une entreprise de
travau agricole je pouvais pas parce que
c'était financier quand tu 4 familial
tes parents sont pas agriculteur c'est
assez compliqué euh
compliqué d'une part financière d'autre
part pour accéder au foncier c'est pensé
comme ça du coup j'ai monté une société
commerciale donc qui fait la prestation
de service donc je travaille pour les
agriculteurs qui sont pas
équipés pour le moment c'est donc un
nomade de l'agriculture le but étant
d'économiser pour pouvoir acheter un peu
de terre en attendant le marathon
continue en route pour le sud du Cher où
Mathieu doit faucher des prix tu
reprends le la la parcelle où tu as fait
l'autre jour ouais tu vas atterrir au
fond ouais il regarde au fond is oui
c'est làbas ok Matthieu n'est pas un cas
isolé s'installer beaucoup y aspirent
mais peu peuvent seul permettre si vous
voulez on a beau ét aidé he quand ça
vaut une fortune ça vaut une fortune au
bout d'un moment tu plafonnes les Z
c'est normal euh là le foncier je vous
dis il a doublé en 10 ans euh ben tu
peux rien ça tu peux rien et puis on on
a des structures qui sont de moins en
moins transmissibles vous comprenez les
structures qui arrivent à 5 6 700
hactares comment vous voulez qu'un jeune
il reprenne ça c'est pas possible c'est
impossible il y a quelques temps de là
on avait des domaines enfermage qu'un
jeun pvit s'installer dessus sur 80
hectares aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
plus le cas on trouve plus de ça c'est
les grosses structures des grosses
structures des grosses structures quoi
alors c'est bien c'est bien pour les
gens qui le qui le font mais bon après
il faut laisser un peu de place aux
jeunes aussi
quoi des prix qui flambent des domaines
agricoles géants impossiblebles à
reprendre
les jeunes comme Matthieu sont dans une
impasse aujourd'hui quand on n'est pas
fils d'agriculteur il faut être nanti
pour s'acheter des
terres les courbes sont éloquantes en 15
ans le foncier agricole a doublé en
France et la région Centre et le Cher
n'échappe pas à la tendance dans ce
département le prix de l'hectare est
passé de 2500 à plus de 4700 € en 13
ans en cause il y a notamment
l'urbanisation les villes grignotent les
campagnes les terres qui restent sont
donc plus cher le moindre lopin mis en
vente attire les convoitises et les
agriculteurs qui partent en retraite
sont placés devant un dilemme vendre un
jeune ou au voisins qui cherch à
s'étendre bon là vous voyez bon ici
c'était les les Génis de 3 ans qui
étaient là en attente d'être mis au
taureau quoi c'était le Jacques Charu a
pris sa retraite l'an dernier il a voulu
transmettre son exploitation à un jeune
mais sa succession
s pas passé comme
prévuurais bien estimé voir des vaches
encore un peu
ici mais bon c'est comme
ça pourquoi il y en a plus de vach ici
parce que ben on n pas réussi le
repreneur a pas réussi à avir les les
prairies et il a pas pu reprendre le
chtel quoi comme beaucoup d'agriculteurs
Jacques Charu n'était pas propriétaire
de toutes ces terres il n'en possédait
en fait fait que 10 % 20 hectares sur
200 pas suffisant pour vivre le reste il
le loit à différents propriétaires et
l'un d'entre eux par peur des impayés
n'a pas souhaité louer un
jeune moi mon but premier c'était
l'installation d'un
jeune un jeune hors cadre familial en
plus et puis qui qui démarre avec avec
zéro c'était vraiment une installation
propre c'était pas un agrandissement
j'estime que il y a pas assz
d'installation de jeûne et que ben il
faut voir dans l'avenir ce qu'on est
encore des agriculteurs dans 20 ou 25
ans qui ne reste pas qu'un ou deux
agriculteurs par par commune il faut il
faut installer des jeunes et et même
tous les agriculteurs vieillissent donc
il faut il faut qu'il y ait des jeunes
qui prennent reprennent le flambeau
résultat des courses l'exploitation a
été démembrée la partie céréalière a
bien été reprise par le jeune mais les
vaches ont disparu des
stabulations alors quand j'ai débuté moi
mais il y a très longtemps j'avais
commencé avec des moutons et après j'ai
acheté des vaches ou et j'ai monté un
chtel chtel moi-même je suis arrivé ben
en 2013 à avoir 150 150 têtes comme
Jacques Charu un agriculteur sur de va
partir en retraite dans les 5 ans et
seulement 60 % seront remplacés par un
jeune la plupart des terres laissées par
les retraités serviront donc à
l'agrandissement des exploitations
voisines ce que combat la Chambre
d'Agriculture du Cher quand on a des
exploitations qui sont viables et qui
permettent à un jeune de s'installer
c'est toujours plus intéressant à mon
sens d' d'installer quelqu'un que
d'agrandir des gens autour donc certes
des fois la confortation elle est
importante puisque il y a des gens qui
ont des petites exploitations donc
récupérer un peu et c'est important pour
leur viabilité mais si la structure le
permet l'installation est toujours mon
sens favorable pour l'agriculture du
département et je pense qu'il faut
vraiment dire que bah si si on transmet
pas les exploitations et ben demain on
aura plus d'agriculteur donc c'est quand
même c'est quand même important parce
que il y a l'agriculture mais il y a
aussi toutes
les enfin tout ce qui tourne autour de
l'agriculture dans le département on a
quand même bah des comment dire des
organisations autour des agriculteurs
qui sont importantes et qui crée de
l'emploi donc ben si on a plus
d'agriculteur ces emploisl on les aura
pas non
plus dans ce contexte certains
parviennent tout de même à s'installer
mais à quel prix gonzac bachelier est
plutôt du genre têtu quand il a un
projet dans la tête il va au bout il
s'est donc installé en mars 2013 dans
cette belle exploitation de 200 hactares
près de Levet en pleine champagne
berichon il a été installé par la Safire
société qui gère le foncier agricole
problème il n'a pas pu discuter le prix
et c'est beaucoup beaucoup
endêé pour s'installer le matériel on le
reprend souvent de fois beaucoup plus
cher qu'il ne au donc pour X raison
et autant autant de remboursement
d'emprint que vous avez c'est autant
d'argent que vous sortez de votre poche
quoi c'est du salaire que vous vous
versez pas hein
donc le marchant bien c'est des freaiss
non négociable c'est des frais très
élevés la saffaires c'est des frais très
élevés c'est non négociable et le
matériel c'est non négociable si vous
voulez moi dans ma position j'étais face
à un agriculteur qui était déjà installé
depuis longtemps qui avait les moyens
d'acheter l'exploitation sans difficulté
au prix donc si je voulais absolument
m'installer chose que je voulais il a
fallu que je fasse la même chose hein
que j'accepte les
conditions les bâtiments les terres le
matériel le marchand bien et la safaire
en tout plus d'un million d'euros à
débourser des annuités Massu lui tombent
dessus
aujourd'hui moi si j'achète pas un
tracteur à 100000 € une maonneuse à
200000 je peux pas récolter mes mes
cultures donc ça ça appartient à la
banque hein donc le le le le le le gros
sacrifice qu'il faut faire c'est qu'il
faut avoir une activité à côté sinon
j'ai pas de salaire et ça ça va
durer le moins de temps je l'espère mais
je pense que ça va durer encore au moins
3 4 ans là vous êtes dans quelle
situation financière en
fait situation
délicate situation délicate j'arrive pas
à faire face à toutes mes annuités de
remboursement lié à l'exploitation il y
a certaines choses qui sont financées en
en court terme donc des choses que je
capitalise pas
et personnellement ma vie de famille
athti et et tout en pti quoi la ferme
financi financièrement dégage pas
suffisamment d'argent et personnellement
à un moment donné je suis moins
disponible dans mon activité salariale
donc j'ai moins de revenu donc tout est
tout est
difficile gonzag est donc bien
agriculteur mais à mi-temps sa force de
travail il la partage entre son
exploitation et son métier de vendeur
d'Anger agricole ce jour-là il se rend
chez un client pour conclure la vente
d'attracteur ça reste voilà
indispensable ça si si je fais pas cette
activité annexe
ouais mon banquier personnel va m'écrire
en rouge sur son tableau et il va avoir
un téléphone rouge il va m'appeler très
très souvent ça va pas bien se passer
surendetté ou sans exploitation ça
n'empêche pas les jeunes agriculteurs de
se mobiliser pour essayer de changer les
choses tous les ans via leur syndicat
ils organisent des forums pour réunir
les futures retraités et les jeunes pour
faciliter la transmission des terres
l'occasion de convier les banques et les
organismes agricoles et parmi ces
organismes il en est un qui a un rôle
clé la saffaire mais au fait c'est quoi
la saffaire c'est une société privée
avec une mission d'intérêt général créée
dans dans les années 60 pour moderniser
l'agriculture une de ses principales
missions aider les jeunes à s'installer
pour ça elle a une
stratégie alors aujourd'hui la Safire
travaille avec des
investisseursin qui portent le foncier
ce qui permet aux jeunes de reprendre
les terres en location ces investisseurs
c'est des gens qui veulent faire des
déplacements dans dans
l'immobilier ce sont des des chefs
d'entreprise ce sont éventuellement euh
des des groupements financiers qui
cherchent à diversifier le leur
patrimoine la Terre est devenue une
valeur refuge un placement qui double en
15 ans attire forcément les
investisseurs la safaire se sert d'eux
pour installer des jeunes mais ce type
d'installation pourrait aussi faire
grimper le prix du
foncier aujourd'hui la Saffire n'est pas
responsable de de ce qui peut se se
passer au niveau de l'évolution du
foncier hein aujourd'hui on intervient
systématiquement en amont des opérations
avec des des discussions des
négociations de manière à à maîtriser
l'évolution du du foncier en aucun cas
on peut on peut rendre responsable un
organisme plus qu'un autre du prix du
foncier la Safire compte en tout cas sur
cette stratégie car depuis plusieurs
années déjà son action est remise en
question notamment par la Cour des
comptes moins de 10 % d'installation de
jeunes en 2012 dérive inefficacité sa
côe de popularité est au plus
bas 25 % des agriculteurs ne lui font
plus confiance d'après un sondage
réalisé par le magazine terres agricoles
en
2012 l'institution semble dépasser par
la loi de l'offre et de la demande il y
a ce que on dit le prix officiel et le
prix officieux en fait tout Lee dira par
exemple sur bourge oui
métaire la safère a contenu on est sur
des prix de 6 7000 € la réalité terrain
est beaucoup plus forte
quoi un cout à l'accès du foncier qui
est énorme
il y a des acheteurs il y a pas de
vendeurs il y a des acheteurs il y a une
terre qui sère il y a 15 personnes
dessus donc c'est l'offre et la demande
après les pour nous on est beaucoup
moins cher que les étrangers beaucoup
moins cher que la Belgique que
l'Allemagne que le que la Hollande même
que l'Italie et l'Espagne donc il y a
aucune raison que le prix baisse il va
continuer à
monter les prix du foncier n'étant pas
amenés à baisser il faut trouver des
alternatives au lycée agricole on
prépare les jeunes à affronter ce milieu
complexe tout spécialement ceux qui
évoluent hors cadre familial
c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'ont pas de parents
agriculteurs depuis une vingtaine
d'années ils sont en pass de devenir
majoritaires dans les classes Damien
fait partie de ses jeunes il passe
aujourd'hui son oral de fin d'année
monsieur vinant et sa femme ont 60 ans
et donc dans une démarche de
transmission progressive il souhaiterait
s'asso avec un jeune pour leur
transmettre progressivement les part
social de l'explloitation l'association
d'un agriculteur avec un jeune c'est ça
la solution le principe est simple
l'agriculteur a monté une société pour
gérer son exploitation le jeune va donc
acheter des pars de cette société pour
s'installer tout en douceur en pouvant
m'installer progressivement ça fait des
des investissements qui sont moins lourd
au départ à l'installation faut pas se
le cacher c'est quand même des sommes
d'argent qui sont assez conséquentes
même si ça reste encore raisonnable la
reprise de part sociale mais oui c'est
au départ on se dit est-ce qu'on va
réussir à
rembourser les l'endettement qu'on dans
lequel on
s'engage Damien sera donc associé le
risque est plus limité les banques
rassuré un modèle plébisité au sein de
l'établissement il y a déjà des jeunes
qui étaient en apprentissage qui ont
ensuite eu une période de salariat chez
leur employeur chez la personne qui les
a formé pour aboutir ensuite à terme à
une installation dans le cadre d'une de
de de part de prise dans la société
agricole constitué pour des jeunes qui
sont hors cadre familial ça peut
ressembler effectivement à un parcours
idéal cela dit il y a pas de recette
miracle il y a tout toutes les solutions
euh à partir du moment où elles
correspondent aux individus peuvent être
positives et
intéressantes autre modèle possible
acheter plus petit c'est l'idée de
Julien broutard il était formateur au
lycée agricole mais il a décidé de
passer à la pratique il va donc élever
de la volaille et des moutons dans une
petite ferme du sud du Cher diversité
petite surface comme dans le temps à
contrepied du modèle
dominant le premier avantage en terme
d'installation c'est de d'être sur
quelque chose qui va être gérable seul
qui va être remboursable seul sans qu'il
y ait de de capitaux qui viennent de
l'extérieur là alors les capitaux ils
viennent de la banque hein mais juste en
faisant appel au au au prêt comme chacun
pourrait faire un prêt pour acheter sa
maison juste en en faisant appel à ça
les banques sont sont prêtes à suivre le
projet allez allez
allez moi c'est c'était ma façon de voir
quoi après il y en a d'autres pour qui
leur façon de voir c'est d'avoir
l'exploitation qui va être la plus
grande possible faire des économies
d'échelle faire faire des des cultures
en nombre réduit pour pour aller pour
aller à l'essentiel
quoi moi mon essentiel c'est d'avoir
d'avoir une exploitation qui soit
tenable par mois et euh et qui soit un
élément de la la vie
du la vie du territoire quoi c'est c'est
ça qui qui était le plus plus important
c'est d'avoir quelque chose
euh où je puisse me retrouver ses
moutons et ses poulets Julien les vendra
en circuit court sur les marchés dans
les drives fermiers ou par Internet plus
coûteux pour le consommateur les
circuits courts sont aussi plus
rémunérateurs pour le producteur
des débouchés innovants qui peuvent
faire vivre ces petites structures il y
a une place pour pour tout le monde quoi
et globalement la la surface agricole
française elle diminue par par
l'urbanisation par le passage des routes
et tout ça et il faut qu'on qu'on soit
qu'on soit compétitif quoi il faut pour
pour pouvoir continuer à vivre et que
l'agriculture française elle
nourrisse la vie française il faut qu'on
continue à être productif et
intelligemment produire intelligemment
c'est l'enjeu des politiques agricoles
de demain la nouvelle loi d'avenir pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et la forêt
a été définitivement adopté le 11
septembre dernier elle va contraindre la
safaire à mieux assumer ses missions
elle prévoit aussi de limiter les
agrandissements pour faciliter les
installations une réforme qui va a
priori dans le bon sens le maintien des
jeunes sur le territoire est
àprit